this morning in our Saturday session of
special performance ahead of next
weekend's Tony Awards Haiti's town up
for Best Musical Best Original Score and
Best Choreography is the most nominated
show of the year the modern day musical
is based on an ancient Greek myth the
cast will perform in just a moment but
first a backstage look at Haiti's towns
unlikely journey to Broadway and the two
women who are the creative forces behind
it
[Music]
the musical Hades town traveled a long
road to Broadway but it arrived with
more Tony nominations than any other
show this year 14 Tony nomination 14
yeah Rachel champion is nominated for
Best Director and aeneas Mitchell is
nominated for best book and Best
Original Score the pair are the rare
female duo
to bring a musical to Broadway I brought
my little five year old when our marquee
first went up to see it but she looked
up and saw the sign and she can read but
he took captive she really loves her and
idolizes Rachel and she's like thank you
mommy and I felt so proud to be able to
show her that sign with our names on it
and that she doesn't know that that's
unusual the night of the Tony
nominations the cast celebrated on the
balcony of Broadway's Walter Kerr
Theatre Hades town is hardly an
overnight sensation Mitchell a
singer/songwriter came up with the idea
more than a dozen years ago I started
writing it yeah in 2006 the piece began
as a DIY community theater project in
Vermont where I used to live we rolled
around in a school bus that was painted
silver so we would tour around and
present it as a concert
[Music]
in 2010 she first recorded Hades town
with musician friends Ani DiFranco and
Justin Vernon of Bon Iver singing lead
role in the beginning were you
envisioning a musical on Broadway
Broadway was not in my yeah not in my
sights at the time but then she met Jeff
Caen and they began to collaborate on a
production that would open at the New
York Theatre Workshop in 2016 where it
won rave reviews at the end of that run
the producers were like well so should
we so we try to make Broadway happen and
I didn't know how badly I wanted it
until they asked we were clear about it
than I was yeah yeah yeah I was like I'm
not sure so you thought why not why not
go to Broadway
I wanted it to refine the show they
first took it to the Citadel Theatre in
Edmonton in Canada in 2017 then on to
the National Theatre in London in 2018
finally this year after Bruce
Springsteen's show ended its run at the
Walter Kerr Theatre Hades town moved in
the thing is its own animal and it has
sort of carried us well I can say for me
personally I think this is one of the
most beautiful things Oliver have been a
part of in my life I don't need
based on Greek mythology Hades town is
the story of Orpheus played by reap
carny who's trying to write a song to
heal the world and his love Eurydice
played by Avon Okla sada who is lured
down to Hades town Orpheus tries to
rescue her from the underworld ruled by
Hades and his wife Persephone the epic
tale is told by Hermes performed by 73
year old Andre DeShields who is
celebrating half a century on the stage
how have you survived fifty years in
theatre it's not an easy career no if
it's not an easy career at all however
it mustn't be an easy career if it's
easy you you aren't paying dues and one
of the reasons that I can perform Hermes
with all his histrionics is because I've
earned him DeShields who starred in
ain't misbehavin The Full Monty and
originated the title role of The Wiz on
Broadway has earned his third Tony
nomination for Hades town it means a lot
it means a lot to me yes it means a
great deal to me
DeShields late parents both had dreams
of being performers he has lived their
dream and after his phone rang with the
news of his Tony nod he turned it off I
shut it off
because I needed to have that
conversation with mom and dad and say
this might be the one I hope it is I
hope so too